le kiss with c'est très simple et oui on
rappelle que le livre de clémentine
s'appelle on s'aimera on en parlera tout
à l'heure puisque on parlera aussi
d'internet parce que c'est vraiment un
contour et oui ça et et les machines je
trouve que c'est ça la magie d'un truc
positif c'est pas du tout une accusation
très positive ce pas messieurs c'est
très positif alors du père il ya jean
michel maire qui avec anthony kavanagh
il ya enora malagré quitte avec
clémentine célarié il ya mathieu
delormeau et un décret kaboul unis se
tournent alors si vous êtes un petit peu
avec elle alors je vous explique le
thème du jeu vous posez des questions
sur l'amour vous allez jouer également
chez vous le couple le plus proche devra
se faire pour un grand bisou voix la
voix le bisou très exactement pour qu'on
voit bien où on va la laisser tomber -
le voir au moins
vous mettez les deux alésiens jean
michel bouquet l'embrasser anthony
passant à entonner vous l'embrassez
jean-michel aussi à l'aise ici c'est
vrai mais taisons un peu alors attention
voici la première question météo bien
quel est le pourcentage de français qui
avoue à garder leurs chaussettes pendant
l'amour
quel est le pourcentage de français qui
avoue avoir gardé leurs chaussettes
pendant la récession
marqué à l'aller vite s'il vous plaît le
plus proche et vous n'invitez des
classes le plus proche les plus proches
d'eux vont s'embrasser allez vite sur ma
terre on y va on y va à l'essai partie
ferme idée on a pour jean michel mr et
anthony kavanagh 28% de français qui
gardent leurs chaussettes pendant
l'amour
enora malagré et clémentine célarié
s'avoue déjà déjà arrivé de sortir avec
un t shirt mais que jamais enfin vous
êtes fous dans nos veines un nombre non
égard de tous les belges est habillée
c'est beaucoup mieux
d'accord vous aviez 45% est ce que c'est
vraiment juste prix c'est plus près par
en dessous au medac la cinu tullaye sont
pas pressés 18% 80 on ferait m 80 non
mais dites pas n'importe quoi vous avez
mis 18 % eh bien eh bien je vous le dis
les plus proches sont matthieu delormeau
et les caps
une % lui pour cent des français gardent
leurs chaussettes pendant l'amour bisous
souffler bijoux un ben amer mais non on
est tous et le plus le plus près qu'ils
s'embrassaient si on avait su on y va on
y va tout d'abord on s'embrasse la ba
oui vous en faites trois sont
neutralisés il faut que ça marque
voilà voilà
et
attention deuxième question pour orner
en jours-ci bisous bisous
combien de partenaires sexuels les
français ont-ils en moyenne dans leur
vie allez-y combien de partenaires
sexuels
les français ont-ils en moyenne dans
leur vie c'est une source de femme
actuelle
allez-y très vite allez on y va on a
trois mini-sommets gens des gens qui me
remercient vite vite vite allez on y va
des cherry oui on nous vire vert en
tient son billet sans frais jean michel
maire anthony kavanagh centraco c'est
votre cas
aujourd'hui oui quoi 5 aujourd'hui jean
michel 0 kas charge de plus mais j'ai
souvent été célibataire
d'accord vous en êtes à combien doit peu
près cent mille fois non d'être 1000
milles
j'ai pas peut-être non oui et j'ai 53
ans si oui c'est pas pareil que konami
clémentine vous avez 18 8
vous étiez d'accord sur le fait qu on
est d'accord d'accord et vous vous avez
combien 24 à bas et la delormeau ali va
alors vous pensez bien je vais vous dire
les français ont en moyenne 10,5
partenaires s'avère qu'ils ont dit
partenaires mais il y en a 05 donc c'est
ceux qui sont touchés avec mathieu
valbuena donc 10,5 et vous êtes les plus
proches un add on joue les scellés de
six voix les i do asie ah oui pas mal
oui en même temps c'est oui c'est pas
mal ah ouais là et puis bon bah les
samares pas sûr et noir marquent
non mais c'est un mari très bien aller
c'est bon ça passe station nous ce qu'on
veut c'est qu'à la fin de leurs mots
galoche chéri kaboul voilà limitons tony
et jean michel mr attention on joue
maintenant justement la question finale
pour le bisou sur la bouche de 20
secondes c'est maintenant très sursis
combien de personnes font l'amour chaque
seconde en france combien de personnes
sur l'amour chaque seconde en france
cette inspiration c'est parti lance en
france ce seront les bienvenues joindre
les plus loin qu'ils devront s'embrasser
aller en lisant on y va aller vite vite
estime emile allais combien de personnes
pour l'amour chaque seconde en france
vont aller vite vite on y va combien pas
combien de personnes font l'amour chaque
seconde en france et c'est là qu'on va
se faire signaler que ça redémarre pas
les quinze mille années de quasi allez
c'est bon en famille à levi johnson et
5000 par ça et c'est parti avec sergent
michel bergue vaut mieux pour clémentine
célarié et vous et vous combien 25000 ce
seront les plus loin qu'ils ne vont
s'embrasser sur la bouche
s'ils peuvent mettre la langue c'est
important mais je ne veux pas qu'on la
voit je veux pas que s'il vous plaît
vous me saouler qu'est ce que vous
voulez tout allait enseigner ce qui
était plus près de la réponse qui s'en
vont - ils clament des règles un peu
particulière
tu vas pas tardé à verser 10 on peut
plus alors je vous le dis il y à chaque
seconde en france 215 personnes qui
feront l'amour chaque seconde
vous êtes donc les plus loin
ok
allez bon voilà une petite musique la
compagnie cole c'est bon pour le moral
allez c'est parti laisse moi faire
cesser le faire ça bouge à noyers sur m6
vous je veux voir les choses là oh oui
maintenant toujours comme ça de
certaines commandes va s'embraser là par
la taille bon vous embrasser écouter
tout le monde connaît plus
sur l'année
aux meilleurs éléments
il met la langue
l'accès
c'est nous
les
touche-à-tout chez vous toucher vous
touchez pour ses bons à très bons
horaires mais bon ça ils aiment ça
oui oui c'est coli qui provoque sa en
but mais tim pas mal du tout moi mais
contre toute attente les biens durables
contre toute attente s'était pas déroulé
oui jean luc jean luc est facile
aujourd'hui
écoutez j'étais citer qu'eux tout début
mais finalement je crois qu'ils
abandonnent et un casque c'est comme en
france des cortèges et non mais j'ai été
très surprise parce que je pensais qu'on
allait collé collé et tout a ouvert donc
j'ai pas pu y aller mais 20 secondes
voici tu as aimé ou pas vous en ai
connais tu peux le dire non c'était moi
le web et moi le vrai rôle appel papy
brossard